خطوه تصعيديه تعقبها تحركات اخرى
في يوم غضب وتجند من اجل التصدي للمخططات
التي تستهدف قطاع الاعلام المنهك اصلا
بازماته الماليه وغياب التشريعات الضامنه
لحقوق الصحفيين بل والتنصل الرسمي من
تطبيق اتفاقات سابقه خاصه تلك المتعلقه
بالمؤسسات الاعلاميه العامه او تلك التي
صدرت في اعقاب الثوره السيطره السلطه
السياسيه على الاعلام العمومي
وكيف حاولت التلفزه العموميه المموله من
دافعي الضرائب الى التلفزه
وصوت واحد وتقوم بالدعايه السوفيتيه
للنظام الحاكم هناك ايضا مساله حريه
الصحافه والتعمير والايقافات والاحالات
المتكرره
موزاييك الخاصه ذات الانتشار الواسع في
تونس اوقف مديرها العام منذ ايام في قضيه
لا تعرف تفاصيلها الا بتصريح محاميته التي
اكدت ان من بين اسباب التحقيق معه والخط
التحريريه للمؤسسه هو تحدي كما اي تحدي
اخر نحن نعيشوه كتحدي للمهده وكتحدي
للايداع كتحدي
لرساله رساله المهنه في الجهه المقابله
يبحث الرئيس قيس سعيد جميع الاتهامات
المتعلقه بانتهاك الحقوق والحريات
ومن بينها حريه الصحافه والتعبير وهل تمت
ملاحقه اي صحفي من اجل عملا يتعلق
بالصحافه
للاسف
اكاذيب
واراجيف يثير المرسوم الرئاسي المتعلق
بمكافحه الجرائم المتصله بانظمه المعلومات
والاتصال مخاوف جديه من اطراف عده نظرا
الى تضمنه عقوبات زجريه قاسيه
وتنزل وفق منتقديه في اطار الطريق الرسمي
على الصحفيين والناشطين تسر نقابه
الصحفيين التونسيين على مواصله تحركاتها
دفاعا عن الحقوق والحريات
وتصديا لما تعتبره خطرا دائما يستهدف مهنه
السحافه
وتساندها في ذلك منظمات حقوقيه ومدنيه في
وقت تعد فيه السلطات نفسها ضامنه لحريه
الراي والتعبير سيف الدين الجزيره
تونس